new role you don't have to ask me if I
want to skip this ad hello I'm at work
I'm spending all morning watching porn
Russian car crash videos and a turtle
[ __ ] issue and you expect me to take
time out of my busy day to watch your ad
you see the irony okay new rule of
Secret Service agents are going to get
drunk and crash their car into the White
House at least have to try to hit one of
the nuts jumping the fence I don't know
what's more embarrassing the accident
itself or the fact that they were so
drunk they accidentally locked their
hookers in the car new rule name your
baby Gary last year fewer than 450 boys
in America and only 28 in England were
named Gary it's almost extinct and
what's wrong with Gary carries the guy
at enterprise who upgraded you to a
Chevy Malibu
Gary's the roadie who checked the mics
at the Whitesnake reunion tour and who
fled to Southeast Asia so we could
continue having sex with underage girls
Gary Glitter Gary it's a great name do
something about it
new rule in order to advance the cause
of racial progress in America the police
have to shoot an unarmed white man
doesn't matter ho just pull up to a
Pete's or a coffee bean ask the first
guy you see coming out the door to prove
he paid for that chai tea latte and when
he reaches in his pocket for the receipt
kill him I mean it's not like he had a
choice he could have been going for a
gun no now that Apple is selling a
$17,000 version of their new I watch
they have to start making cocaine they
can call it I blow I've blown you'll
wonder how you ever got anything done
without it